okay guys it's just date and I'm so
excited because today we have gotten one
of the Mavic two zooms here to test out
there are two new drones in the Maverick
family there's this one this is the zoom
and there is the Ematic 2 pro version
now what's exciting is both of these
drones are the first of their kind in
portable consumer drones the pro version
has a Hasselblad camera with a one-inch
sensor and this one has a twenty four to
forty eight millimeter optical zoom I
cannot wait to try out both versions but
today we've got the zooms so let's unbox
I'm also excited about the upgraded
flight time it says will get thirty one
minutes which is great because more
flight time means more fun so here it is
we have got the controller looks to be a
little bit bigger than a previous
version and here's our ona your beefy
does have a little bit of a weight to it
it does feel a little bit heavier than
the previous Mavericks and by heavier I
mean you barely know box another box
another one so before we get started I
believe it is a size comparison so this
is the mavic air and this is the
brand-new
Matic 2 so it is quite larger than the
Mavic air and now in comparison to the
medic Pro platinum pneumatic two is a
little bit taller it's slightly heavier
like really not that much at all but as
for controllers this is the Matic
platinum so it's a little bit thicker
one of the features in the Maverick air
that I loved in the controller is the
removable joysticks they hide in here as
a nice little storage compartment that
makes it so much easier to travel with
these so that's very exciting let's open
this guy up just see what it looks like
all out this looks like a much stronger
gimbal than our previous versions
oh yeah this this is industrial this
also now has omnidirectional optical
sensing so that basically will give you
way more coverage if you are coming up
on obstacles it's not entirely 360 it
has top and bottom left and right and
front and back the left and right is
only available with active track and
tripod mode but for the most part this
is gonna provide you some really great
coverage as far as obstacle avoidance
here's our battery let's take a look at
this whoa this is way bigger than
the other Mavic battery is here's the
math at platinum and here's the
brand-new havoc to battery and it is way
thicker so that battery's dead so I'm
gonna need to charge this before we go
out it's got a cable charger extra
propellers and of course paperwork so
here's two different courts there is a
microUSB so for most Android phones and
also a USB C version for newer Android
phones and hopefully one day the iPhone
extra joysticks and here's our gimbal
and lens protection so this look has got
an extra little thing on it now now that
our unboxing is complete it's time to
update the firmware as soon as this
battery charges and we're gonna head
outside so let's go
[Music]
smack - zoom is all set up and ready to
go I've updated the firmware so
basically what we're gonna do right now
is I'm just gonna take it for a flight
and see how it flies later on in the
video we're gonna be going into a little
bit more depth of some of the features
and some comparisons to some other
drones that are out right now right now
I just want to fly this freakin thing so
let's let's just go
wait let me calibrate first I don't want
to get too ahead of myself guys like my
hat I don't care if you don't like it I
can't see the screen so I may have
turned off obstacle avoidance because I
want to cruise through this little area
right here
oh my gosh
it really went up quick
well I'll see you later
[Music]
you gotta fly back through there there's
a hand
[Music]
[Applause]
zooom so here's our zoom they can use
this little guy zoom into those trees
[Music]
quick shot so here's the dolly zoom
[Applause]
[Music]
so now I just switched it to 60 frames a
second so we're gonna get a little bit
closer the waves and so you can get some
really cool slower mo shots
[Music]
now let's try 120 frames a second I'm
such a sucker for slow-mo I shoot in 120
all the time when I'm using my Sony
cameras so now we've got it in the drone
this will be shooting in 1920 by 1080
120 frames a second let's go
[Music]
like I'm not even that close to him but
it looks like I am he was going like
this he was nudging he was nudging the
other seal
so I just switched it to h.265 we're
shooting 4k 30 and we're shooting an a
it's it's but what does it the Cinna
like profile so it's a much flatter
color so this will allow you to be able
to color grade way more accurate to what
you guys might have in mind
see you guys honestly if it starts
coming towards you just duck because
[Music]
it's a tough job I haven't even flown
thematic to pro yet so Wow
there's gonna be I'm so happy now we do
your charge batteries cuz we only have
two so I wanted to show Jenna some
things will be shots and what's great is
because some of these shots especially
some big shots ah you can save it
directly to your phone and it creates
like mini little Izzy's everything this
shot right here
I am pretty sure I should have hit
something but I did are you ready for it
we're in London taking a little break
charging up our batteries and they were
to go film some more but my initial
reaction of this thing is I am in love
she don't wanna do more do I wanna
what's the other way it's a one-inch
sensor and so it'll have better do they
both have always and you can shoot 10
bit which is so I like to do sunset so
if you like this sensor have you better
put something right click it for dark
you can cut this this
now we're at the part of the video where
we're going to some four different
drones first we have the Mavic Platinum
the Phantom 4 pro the Mavic air and the
brand-new Mavic Pro to zoom Nathan is
going to attempt to fly us on the same
flight pattern on all four drops
now it's basically erasing at the time
the Sun is setting
we've got to get a hyperlapse and we've
got to do some tracking on the bikes so
let's see what we can do on two
batteries
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
had so much fun shooting this video it
was a pretty quick turnaround time we
basically shot this in a day and I'm now
editing and it's 4:00 a.m. there's so
many more things that I want to test out
on this drone I also can't wait to try
automatic trooper oh it's gonna be
really cool to see how that one inch
sensor performs in different flying and
lighting conditions hope you guys enjoy
this here - thank you - Nathan before
coming out and shooting this video with
me he's an incredible drone pilot so
it's really fun because when I'm not
flying I could be doing cool things and
he can be getting cool drone shots of me
doing cool things like riding the bike
be sure to subscribe and at the Bell so
you guys will see some more fun videos
from me at hopefully very soon but now
go to bed
enjoy
[Music]